[Music]
hey guys brand new podcast just sit him
a man cave minding my own business not
really sure if I'm gonna do a sketch
this weekend wait who's that walking out
to the man cave why its my good friend
Tom Segura let me let him in hey Tommy
come on how you doing buddy what's on
your mind I'm sorry that I'm fat I just
realized how fat I was it's ridiculous
sometimes I just look in the maritime
like 50 I think we all have those
moments Tom I think this whole fat
shaming camp rain is really like shine
the light on how I can sometimes live
unhealthy to and let myself go but thank
god we did it cuz I'm feeling good man
I'm down 25 pounds here let me show me
take my shirt off real quick look at you
yeah the thing that is it's not so much
about working out for me it's diet and
that's where I go off the rails on the
road so I'm kind of eating lean proteins
and mostly greens and just drinking
vodka sodas what about you how you been
eating I did go out to eat eat another
fat person you ate a human being Tom not
only is that illegal to murder someone
but it's got to be tough on you I mean
just simply digesting toe nails and
teeth I feel horrible about my digestive
system of course man I mean you had to
process their hair how did you eat all
that hair oh my god what was the next
day like I had a catastrophic diarrhea
well that's to be expected buddy listen
you got to stop this behavior right now
here's what you need to do you need to
change your diet and you need to get
back on the horse you need to start
working out again and for God's sakes do
cardio you you can't let cardio
intimidate you what are you doing right
now for cardio but
TV you gotta do more than just watch TV
tom I mean look at me I'm running five
miles a day you win don't give up tom
this is a contest that we can both win
all we got to do is get out of obesity
and just into a regular overweight and
Ari has to take us to Paris France to go
to that soccer game you imagine how much
fun Paris France is gonna be I wonder
what their croissants taste like Oh
their croissants are gonna be fantastic
and you can have as many as you want cuz
the weight loss that will be over were
you gonna put those croissants Tommy my
stupid fat mouth put as many as you want
your stupid fat mouth my friend okay sit
down I gotta start my podcast ladies and
gentlemen real quick dates coming up
this month this weekend the 15 16 17 on
at the Fort Lauderdale improv in fort
lauderdale out at the Hard Rock Casino
levity live to 29 through the 31st in
Oxnard California and we are starting
January often tensely I'm going to be in
New Jersey at the stress factory the
fifth sixth and seventh american comedy
company the 12th 13th and 14th in san
diego and on the 21st i will be in
boston at the wilbur theater get your
tickets helium buffalo comedy off
broadway para live in bellevue and that
brings us to februari 14th practically
where me re and Tom are going to Paris
and we are going to find out who's doing
this gonna pay for this [ __ ] bet that
has changed my life I feel so good i'm
about to get on the treadmill today's
podcast this is a good this is a good
one especially if your podcast fan like
myself you're going to really really
love this this guy not only has a great
podcast that's been around I think 7 99
years it's called comedy film nerds but
he has a movie it's called earbuds I am
in it and it is all about podcasting and
you can get it off his website he tells
you in the podcast ladies and gentlemen
put your hands together for grant Elwood
all right Tom come on let's hop up on
the treadmill okay here we go
well you're walking really heavy buddy
oh my god
[Music]
start and explain to your fans hey guys
I don't know we're talking to him right
now all right yeah I think I think I
don't think anyone would be upset that i
advertised let's do that's money that's
money that that keeps you off you could
not be on the road as much I like be on
the road though I mean I loved I look
here's the thing I I would love to I
would love to take one more week off a
year a month maybe right now I'm doing
three weeks a month which it can be
aggressive at times but I really love it
like I had [ __ ] you I I was out of stand
up yeah it wasn't out of Santa I think I
always thought I was still in standup
but to my friends they were like no you
were out of stand up like Tom and and
Bill and Joe were all like yeah you were
not working the way you should have um
when I was doing the travel stuff right
and now I'm I was like now that I'm on
the road as much as I am I'm like oh
yeah I was not writing at all like I was
just hosting by and just getting checks
to go in and do an hour that I knew I
could do it was really cheating myself I
was writing this weekend I suit some of
the best writing sets i've ever had this
weekend but yeah I want to i'd like to
start advertising so if you're an
advertiser and you're like I don't even
know how it works that's how far out
removed I am like someone's like oh you
should go to saw like some place I was
like why don't want to leave my network
I like all things comedy well there's
there's way like so so comedy film nerds
is with all things comedy yeah and we
get some ads through that so Matt's
through them but I won't like I'm
talking I want like an ad person the way
like you know so I'm doing it all the
time yeah we have a guy that goes gets
as first two um and you know he tracks
down companies basically he's a guy that
listens to a lot of podcasts himself so
he'll be like oh I heard this company on
a bunch of shows they'll they'd love to
yeah when he does vodka sent me a bunch
of stuff but they're not they're not
gonna numbers you're doing you could be
making you could be doing enough to take
yourself all those that single downloads
that's for a single person when I do to
people and we drink there through the
[ __ ] roof
Lee like yeah like through the [ __ ]
roof like double that for four first
week for first week downloads I don't
count anything after first week like I
mean I look at it but like I look for
what its gonna do the first week that's
what everyone's going to hear it right
um but yeah I did one with bill byrne
Tom Segura and we just drank at the am
but we smoked cigars that was a very
high rate of podcast and I did one with
Ari Shaffir and steve byrne is easy what
I also started doing was changing my
intros so that people would want to
listen to them so now I do sketch it
that's awesome so bad so bad it's just
me listening to a sound effect like New
York city traffic or a horse running
down the street and doing both the
voices just like it verse but I but it
sounds so silly I have so much fun doing
it I don't even really write it I just
improv it right till I get to like how I
introduced I don't know how I'll do want
this one but like I try to make it so
that I just do my tour dates and then
and so and that way if I do to have ads
to have these characters read them would
be so much I think people would listen
to them one of me I want people to
listen to the beginning of my podcast
the first six minutes but uh I'm
involved with a company have you heard
about laughable yes [ __ ] love them
really I just started using their app I
just started working with them me arion
Fitzsimmons are all working with them I
love their app because like they
contacted us yeah and they were like
wanting us to do some stuff we were
thinking about it because we just were
max for anything and then the guy was
like saw earbuds and was like are we
really got to do some together I love
that movie by the way oh thanks I love
that movie but you know what i realized
that movie first of all I want to know I
want to know more about um Schmidt is it
Schmidt Schmidt via Mike Schmidt I knew
I he was with jimmy pardo right he was a
guest he and when never not funny first
started it was him in part oh yeah and
then um they did that for about a year
or so and then it didn't work out
between them and then Mike started his
own show and and Matt belknap kind of
became the co-host of never done in two
Matt belknap one time at a show and I
heard him talking I went oh my god yeah
it was so [ __ ] creepy that's the
server those who don't know earbuds is a
documentary you started making probably
like two and a half years ago was it
doable almost three we did the
crowdfunding we shot footage it at the
2013 pod fest to use for the Kickstarter
video the Kickstarter campaign ran in
February of 14 and then it funded which
was it's awesome but it's also the most
stressful thing dude we went we raised
140 grand holy [ __ ] we were 60 70 grand
short four days out and I was like oh
it's done it's not happening yeah like
we rate we hit it with 30 minutes to go
that's when those things fun though I
know that's like you know Gino zane
lamprey at all i know the name Zane's
funded like multi-million dollar oh no I
did talk to him because he was the guy
who gave us this pep talk in the middle
of our campaign we were like oh this
ain't gonna happen he goes no no we were
like 200 grand short or some crazy
number like that and funded with three
days and we were like what yeah and it's
true it happens and like the big donors
the five and ten thousand dollar donors
started dropping in the last 20 hours
dude I I'm thinking about you ready for
this I'm thinking about no not to change
subjects although that's all I penis
thing to do these days is I'm thinking
about crowd funding a dieter date in
Detroit you absolutely shed like going
going cuz I'd like to do Detroit the
mark Ridley's comedy castle doesn't need
like Eden he sells out every ticket any
show anyway so he doesn't need to
overpay me right as he's already getting
a ticket sales and I was like might be
an easy way a surefire way to know
you've sold the thing and then you ready
for this I'm thinking about like $25
tickets for the theater do is like 600
cedar maybe and then for an extra
hundred dollars or maybe like fifty
dollar I don't come up the price point
throughout throwing a breakfast party
for everyone who wants to come out
breakfast with me that's a great idea I
get my hotel I'll cater it I'll [ __ ]
fill it up with booze we get there it's
early so you get early morning drinking
and you just and then I catch a flight
out that night I'm like [ __ ] yeah have
like a great get like a chef to come in
and really like nice bacon and [ __ ]
like eggs benedict dude that's the great
thing with crowdfunding whatever the
[ __ ] you want to do yeah I want to have
a breakfast [ __ ] booze party after my
dupe do it like we did this thing so so
Chris Mancini my co-host crowdfunded a
graphic novel right yeah had an old
screenplay lying around and it was like
ah I was like I want to make this into a
graphic novel so we crowd for it one of
the one of the levels was so comedy
filmers we do regular episodes where we
talk about a bunch of movies and then we
do like a spoiler app like we did one
for Doctor Strange will do one for rogue
one where all we do is talk about the
movie we call it a spoiler because we've
talked about the ending and we warn
people ahead of time like you know so
it's a thing that that fans dig and we
said for a thousand bucks you get to
pick the movie we go out to dinner we we
do um you get to pick the film and then
we'll record a spoiler rep about
whatever movie you want to talk about
and you're in it and it's your episode
oh shut up it was awesome we sold like
three or four of them and while fans
were just like yeah I'm in I just want
to sit and talk movies with you guys and
it's like who would have like we're a
fan last year we just jokingly said oh
man you know we want to go see Star Wars
of force awakens because it came out
they release it in Australia 36 hours
ahead of the states and we just made a
joke like we want to go see at first so
if anyone's got five grand haha send it
to us a fan did and we went to Australia
to watch star wars are you [ __ ] me
no we flew there 17-hour flight got
there crash for a couple hours it was a
midnight screen cuz first of all their
movies release on thursday we ours
release on friday oh so it was
technically Wednesday night you know
1201 a.m. thursday or whatever Oh
dude we got there we got interviewed by
this local TV stations like we're these
crazy Americans flying try to plug in
any comedy while you're over there um it
was such a last-minute thing we like I
think I did a set or something but it
wasn't even like we could put together a
tour just this guy did it in like two
weeks out and we were like okay I guess
we're going so [ __ ] awesome dude and
we assumed he lived in Australia nope
just lived in iowa and wanted because
here's what we did we went to a midnight
screening and then went to a bar next
door and recorded a spoiler up about the
movie we just saw and released a movie
to people in the sun up so it's not even
[ __ ] god I love this world right god
I love this world and this guy was like
I just want to hear you talking about it
before I can see it shut and we
partnered with this guy steals honors it
does this podcast steal wars it's all
star wars yeah he's an Australian dude
he set up the screening it was like the
coolest that's [ __ ] insight that's
why when you're like I wanna do a
breakfast show in detroit yeah of course
you should yeah I talk to I actually
talked to Kickstarter they came into my
man cave to pitch it to me and I said
there's two things I want to do I want
to do a cruise and I want to do I want
to do I want to do Detroit I just know I
have a lot of listeners in Detroit and
and so everyone was like they're like do
it so I gotta I gotta start I got to do
it that's the other [ __ ] problem with
this business so cool things have
changed I would love an assistant and I
know guys I know I say that all the time
and everyone hears that like I'm your
guy I'm your guy okay here's the caveat
you gotta live in [ __ ] LA I know I
can't I can't roll the dice on you
changing your life and moving to LA to
bug him for something that may or may
not work out like I'll be red bana no I
swear to God I loves all of doing
smoking pot and driving fast cars you're
like huh so um but I need you to be
focused if you're gonna be these love of
[ __ ] decisions I do everything myself
with you I post this I edit this I we
started to get like interns and stuff
for comedy film is just because we were
like we could barely but you have
another guy you do it with so yeah you
guys can split up the duties yeah and
but also it that would be easier if I
had to find a partner and
like we should get an intern then that
makes sense but me isn't it that's it's
almost like a prayer it seems weird you
know it's like having I had for a second
i had this guy who's really great really
[ __ ] focused um but I kind of dropped
the ball and I just I didn't follow up
with him and I'm a big flake too I like
to drink that's my big problem because I
like to go on the road and like get off
the [ __ ] grid and like just have
drink and no one get a hold me and I'm
like just doing dates and I love that
[ __ ] yeah but uh but yeah I love that
movie i sadly i didn't i didn't catch
the last quarter of it because uh i was
watching it in Tampa last weekend i
guess and i went to go watch it again
the rest of it this weekend and the
password you gave me read i'll give it a
new one yeah but it's [ __ ] awesome
because one of my favorite things about
it is i am more than anything a
podcasting fan so like I was watching it
as a fan like I like and then I saw me
in it and I went oh [ __ ] that's right i
was in this well you're i was thinking
about this driving over here how you're
in it and what you say everything is
such the beauty of podcasting so like we
had raised the money and i can i call
brian redban I said hey I just want to
like have me on one of your ice house
chronicles yeah and we'll just come in
we'll shoot an interview with you
beforehand and we'll just kind of show
that world in the pot you know that's a
podcast community is very much about
everybody support you know and you just
show up and just start talking on camera
and you know Steve Agee just pops in and
we interview him Logan's there and he's
willing to talk to us which was awesome
but then you say something the thing I
loved about directing the movie was I
obviously learned a lot of great things
from fans and what what this means to
them just listen to this but I learned
so much from other comedian and
podcasters like you made such a great
point and it's why I put in the movie
you go change the dialogue between
comedians and fans a hundred percent you
know you said that and I was like so
many times when I was interviewing
people a comic like you would say
something I go yeah that's right you
know and I do this and it was
I learned a lot about how cool it is and
it reaffirmed so much stuff for me um
you know like Todd glass says um you
know the audience that shows up your
podcast on it they're perfect he made
such a good point goes you know
comedians our podcast like all my fans
are idiots he goes that's your fault you
you created that yeah you know like you
get we get to cultivate who our fans are
it's not like a TV show where I have to
play this character on the TV show and
it attracts a certain type of fan and so
those these are my fans I'm we get to
sit here and talk and be uh we're not
doing characters we're not doing bits
yeah and we get to it you know this we
get to cultivate our fan base our way
that's really interesting i don't think
i ever saw it that way now you say that
my my i would say fans i think i have i
have basically a trickle-down fans it's
like people who love i think my fans are
people who love rogan sure people who
love uh like are their fans of podcasts
yeah and so and I think that's where
they connect with me is they know I'm a
fan of podcast I remember I was in a
Scotland one week one doing TV and I
just put it out on Twitter I was like if
anyone wants to have a beer with me in
Scotland hit me up and these three guys
took a train in and we sat down and had
a beer in between while I was shooting I
just bounced cuz they were doing b-roll
I went how to be with these three guys
and it was so crazy they were like hey
uh did you listen to Rogan this week and
I said nose on it and he's like Bobcat I
was like shut the [ __ ] up and I was like
wait talent and we talked about Rogan's
pot we did right they weren't fanning
out on me we were just talking about a
podcast we at all listen to I do that I
mean if I had a nickel for every time I
had a fan go let me see your top
podcasts and I pull up my phone may go
here's what I subscribe 2 and I flipped
to it and then they do that oh I've
never heard that and then they download
it like some guy this weekend showed me
there's a podcast all about West world
oh it's kind of it's called a bald man
or something I don't I'm I don't know
I'm on the phone but I downloaded it I
was like I'll be listening to that on
the flight home
listen to podcasts on the flight home
last night um but I run into people is
so funny I ran into a guy flying to
Japan and he had a death squad shirt on
and that he looked at me he was like
holy [ __ ] man the machine and I go yeah
he goes you're wearing a [ __ ] rogan
jerk like should I am like it's like I
think that's the cool thing who do you
think the fur who's the first podcast
you started listening to where you were
like God you know I've always just sort
of my vol ways cherry-picked based on
guest or topic yeah so I've never been
like oh I listen to this one religiously
I've always been like oh I want to hear
what that guy says Patton if he pops up
on anything yeah our life [ __ ] in you
know or like Marin oh I want to hear
Robin Williams or oh I gotta listen to
Obama talk or you know um that's prob
ama ones by the most downloaded podcast
in history I'd guess it's up there I
would love to see stats on that it's
great i mean that's um and since you
missed it I mean that's in the movie too
is we have the audio from that and we
got photos from the White House of Obama
and Marin in his garage that was one of
the coolest things for me it's so funny
like because of doing the movie and and
and you know co-producer in Los Angeles
podcast festival I'm so much unlike the
production end of it that like the film
helped me kind of go back to being a fan
a little bit because with el ipod fest I
have to sort of listen to ten minute
clips of a bunch of shows to find new
podcasts to bring into the festival and
so but like I remember listening to the
marin obama interview and I was like
yeah this is what all those fans in the
film talked about I feel like I was
hanging out with the president yeah I
felt like I was just he was just having
coffee with a buddy and I got to go wow
cuz it wasn't slicked up I mean he's the
president he knows his talking points
and you know I mean obviously you know
like this there was a there was a
meeting about what he's supposed to talk
about you drop the n-bomb yeah I know it
was nice you know and he just but it was
my mom like you doing Mia I know
he was like there's the president it was
like it was so it was so like I so get
the personal connection of it you know
like people are that were in their ears
right now it's that like TV is it
literally at a distance you know what I
mean yeah movies that I love I love
going to the movies it but it's it's a
bigger thing it's a show it's a it's you
know it's lit and sound and all this
stuff this is just like you're having
this personal conversation and people
are here participate like like I always
think about that obama thing made me
think about like god i wish i had a time
machine or you know when I die I want to
just sit and talk like miles davis and
winston churchill or something like that
you know it like and this potty is like
holy [ __ ] through name one sitting
president that did an interview like
that nothing never never I've never did
ever sadly I think we all be able to get
Trump on our podcasts I think he's gonna
be hey I think I can tell his him to it
you I wouldn't be shocked to be started
his own podcast I love these tweets I
love that he tweets it makes me it is me
hit this his presidency has brought me
so much joy I have never been a happier
at just like when he just he was like
Saturday Night Live not funny overrated
you just like who the [ __ ] do you think
you are I know [ __ ] is wrong with you
he's like a 15 year old boy I love him
I'm [ __ ] I'm gonna be so sad when
they assassinate him oh yeah I'm a
telling that joke on stage in the middle
of this country and it's not been
getting laughs weird um yeah weird uh
but uh but yeah the podcasting for me I
think was I I mean I've said this ad
nauseam but the first time i met joe i
listen to his podcast so much that when
i went to his door he opened his door
and i was like he was like what's up I
was like I'm gonna need to see your dog
I'm gonna DC your deprivation tank needs
he a pool table and then get high and
i'll be ready to do this and I was like
I've been listening to way too much of
this podcast and he was like and it's
joe so caught off guard he's like okay
and so we went and showed me his dogs
show me the deprivation tank we got high
we did the podcast and I was like and
now and then I remember driving home I
was like that's probably not the best
way to meet Joe I probably should have
been cooler
I was so [ __ ] I was such i'm still a
fit massive fan of his podcast right um
it it's such a it's such a I mean he's
he's like such a great example right so
he's you know he came up in very much
traditional meet you know he came
traditional media Kim you know news
radio and and doing stuff like that and
and what was that NBC show the fear
factor fear factor man show you know man
show all that stuff and UFC and then his
podcast obviously like you say it has
some trickle down and has some crossover
but it's such its own animal and it's he
can do whatever like it's so cool I love
seeing people in that like Aisha or
somebody that has all this traditional
media but they're doing the podcast out
of the purity of it and the love of it
you know he doesn't need the money from
his ad sales for his podcast he's doing
it because he wants to have that forum
to just say whatever the [ __ ] he wants
to talk about he's doing it you know
Chris Rock with before he did his uh his
fur is first the big bigger and blacker
maybe the big special the way everyone
liked I think it's Cornel West is the
black guy with the afro and the glasses
and sometimes a scarf or the Ascot yeah
Cornel West by the way I don't know if
this is true this is maybe what I kind
of heard but I but whatever part I
glommed onto this is what what was right
right before Chris Rock start doing that
special did that special Cornel West
said hey man you're you're a young black
man in this in this business I think you
should be hanging out with the greatest
minds of the of the world and we do a
sunday night dinner where they come over
to my house and we just talk politics
and we talk about life and we talk about
everything you should come to these so
Chris Rock started going it was cornel
west south where he would have these
Sunday night conversations and everyone
would talk about smart [ __ ] and Chris
Rock was like I got like it was like
going to college yeah it was like I
learned so much and I remember being so
jealous of that and then when Joe
started doing it the way he's doing it
now like I love this podcast the
beginning when it's just not comics and
Eddie Bravo and [ __ ] tape I mean I
love
still and he still has that as a
definite part of the podcast but him
bringing in people like scientists
talking like dude I I have gotten so
much smarter just listening to his
[ __ ] podcast at Versailles think
people get Dumber listening to mine but
but but he had a guy I'm gonna say this
guy's name because this podcast was so
[ __ ] great um but eyes are going on
me I think I'm getting old oh dude I'm
fighting the reading glasses fight oh I
got I got readers like I got readers so
I could read things um due to his
podcast with Kevin Smith the other day
was [ __ ] amazing holy [ __ ] Jon Jones
an amazing podcast even L is always
great Wow Jordan Peterson did you listen
to it this guy is [ __ ] fascinating he
is what you'd want like he's fighting
political correctness and social justice
warriors he's not fighting it like an
from an ignorant standpoint he's
fighting the absurdity of it and it it
was eyelid I've listened that pod has
played three times and it's raillery our
podcast this guy is so [ __ ] smart and
Joe possibly I mean if they're gonna
give a potty to anyone Joe would get a
[ __ ] the best interview I've ever
heard him don't do it was so how so like
just in the questions she was asking and
Joe's being fair and representing other
sides and like I'm just making it really
I was sitting there going this is one of
the greatest conversations I've ever got
to listen to and that's what it was it
was just listening to a conversation of
two very intelligent men talk about the
what is happening in this country and in
Canada with uh it was [ __ ] amazing
and so like so like Joe wasn't agreeing
with him all the way but was like not I
wasn't a fight he argued nor was he can
only pass it wasn't given a free pass he
wasn't disagreeing with them he was just
asking him questions and the guy was
answering them and telling them things
and then Joe would be light-hearted as a
comedian should in like great [ __ ]
moments apparently uh there was a guy
who who's transgender who argued this
guy that there's no no scientific diff
friends between men and women and lost
it and I was like well you can't [ __ ]
make that statement it shows like this
guy's going through a sex change like
there's no it was it was just a really
great [ __ ] interview I mean I that
that's that's what I I also i really
could have done I could have had I I
could have had had your movie like as I
was watching it I ended up having to go
to the tampon probably do a show and I
was like I'll pause it I'll start it up
again in my head I was like oh this is
just like a great podcast I don't want
it to [ __ ] end I didn't want your
movie to end I wanted it to be a TV
series haha I mean dead serious I'm I
was like they need a mattress in the TV
series every week profile a different
podcast I'd be [ __ ] there's so many
great podcasts and I'd love to know more
about I'd love to get back story about
oh yeah never not funny is one of the
ones where you're like that's one of the
og's in this game yeah hardcore well
that was the thing and it's so great to
hear you say that because when we were
editing it we were like let's make this
documentary like a podcast where Chris
and I would come in there's voiceover
but not in the way like you would have
narration in a documentary but way a
podcast would be yeah and you know we
shot so much footage you know we sell an
hour of bonus coverage on the site but
we're going to keep releasing because
there was there was whole interview is
that like we couldn't use that are
fascinating that are just fantastic and
it's like I would love to do what you
said of like I haven't thought of that
about making it a TV show where like
this week in podcasting or something
because I learned I mean to I'm being
you're hitting something right a nail on
the head right now I would watch every
[ __ ] week if you had a show much like
[ __ ] NFL tonight Sports Center or
anything that covers anything where you
talk about what's good and podcasting
that week profile a new podcast do a
[ __ ] biography of an old podcast and
then highlight great podcasting moments
cuz that's my [ __ ] I'm into that [ __ ] I
like like like um I was just thinking
man I just lost my train of thought but
like like when Jimmy Pardo his
brother-in-law what this yeah Daniel
like
all right yeah that was lived out on the
podcast I think I remember crying on
that podcast because Jimmy starts crying
and then I'm crying Andrew I'm sorry not
Daniel andrew koenig so yeah andrew
koenig is is Jimmy's brother in law he
was also boner from growing pains which
I mean that isn't that is done it's also
the son of check that you know Walter
can I go play check off on Star Trek so
it's like you know it's it's it was such
an intense thing when that happened and
one of the reasons I wanted to ask you
me about it and I was very I was very
like all these interviews I went in and
said look if you don't want to talk
about this yeah I don't or even after
the interview if you want me to cut it I
will you know and I said I before the
interview like I was going to
sandbagging I've known Jimmy for
twenty-some years I said like I'd like
to have you tell the story about what
that going through when Andrew went
missing and how the fans responded to
that you want to talk about you know
pulling fans together it was it was in
in the midst of another really it was a
tragedy it was awful he went missing and
then he later he took his life you know
he was he was battling with depression
but the podcasting community rallied
when they were looking for him you know
and it was just like the fact that the
podcast community would do that it they
did it as though it was just like you
would be like as though your high school
like you know like all your high school
friends like hey this guy's missing and
everyone from your high school rally
together and there was a phone tree you
know like it was that kind of thing but
it was literally all over you know it
was just it was it was so it was in the
midst of this it's such conflicting
emotions because it's it's tragic that
he you know that he decided to take his
own life and that's one of the things
the movie touches upon his his mental
illness and you know when we went into
to like I knew I was getting of you
Jimmy and he was going to talk about
that I know I was gonna interview Paul
Gilmartin it doesn't mental illness
happy hour yeah I love that by public go
Martin Martin is the he's doing work I
mean he's doing noble work you know like
he's like he goes oh I found you know he
he's thinking about what podcast to do
is remember talking to him about I said
Gilly I've known for million years I
call him gila is like Gilead it's a [ __ ]
ton of work but it's the most empowering
thing you're ever going to do in show
business you know you have complete
control over it and that's another great
example of what should my podcast be
about whatever you want you want to talk
about mental illness you get to do that
you wanted you want to interview like
Joe Rogan does one week a UFC fighter
the next week a guy that's you know as
this heavy social commentary stance or
whatever you want to call it it's
fantastic and so but when we were
interviewing when we were doing earbuds
we did a lot of fan interviews we'd set
up like come by the improv and combine
ered mount and we did say knees in
Chicago and a couple other places in
Australia and we just said we announced
on our podcast will be here you know
saturday from 12 to five come by we'll
do a ten-minute interview and that's
when we started to realize we need to
spend a lot more time on the mental
illness aspect but so many people came
in off the street dude this I mean you
know this is this is now that I realize
in the middle of this this is kind of a
meta podcast because we're talking about
pot if you're listening to podcast you
love podcast we were listening this key
level we're talking it's like it's like
almost like this you know but uh but
that it really is crazy that how many
people come to this medium for sanity it
was you know this this girl that walked
in off the street Allison in Sydney
Australia and she's featured in the film
and she just talked about she's like you
know grandma I came from an imposing an
abusive marriage you know he was
physically and mentally abusive and I
had to deal with PTSD and she's like I
know you've had to deal with that cuz
I've talked about on my show and I was
at first I was like wait how do you when
I was like and I was like oh yeah
because you know I had some stuff from
childhood but also I did a bunch of USO
tours and a couple of like one of them
we like came under fire and almost got
blown out of the sky so loud noises and
helicopters freaked me out you know I
was in Afghanistan we were in a
firefight in a Black Hawk helicopter so
I've talked about that on my podcast and
so she was like but it was cool because
cuz hi it opened up on our podcast she
felt comfortable coming and doing an
interview on camera these are people who
aren't performers they're not you know
you and I can just yeah okay camera
interview bing bang they're nervous they
walk in they see the big lights in the
Cameron they get no but she was
comfortable enough to open up with us
and it's she's her storyline is in the
film and it's like it's it's it was so
it was it was like it was such a pretty
like a privilege and an honor and a big
responsibility I felt like a
responsibility like we gotta handle this
the right way yeah because you go back
to Joe Rogan you know he even liked his
think one of his posted tweets is like
we have a mental illness problem
disguised as a gun problem and we hit
you know like he's addressing it and in
this country we haven't we haven't dealt
with the fact that there's a huge mental
illness problem in this country we just
we just don't and it's good that we need
to have these conversations you know
every time there's a mass shooting nine
out of ten times it's someone that
suffered from some type of mental
illness that wasn't treated yeah you
know and so it was really cool to to go
through all that with the film and and
you you know a documentary is very you
learn so much you know like all these
people sharing all this stuff and how a
podcast they know this woman was like I
couldn't function because my husband was
so abusive and I got out of that
relationship and I needed podcast to
help rebuild who I was and you're
sitting you're going you mean when Chris
and I just [ __ ] get pissed off about
a shitty movie like let that you know
like just sitting in this man cave
[ __ ] around talking about the road
like really that helps that matters and
yeah oh yeah it does yes I know I know
it does for me you know one of my one of
my go-to things is um you know podcast
from you're like a little bit like a
like a warm blanket when i get home off
off when I'm on the road and I'm in a
hotel room I just thrown a podcast and I
can let it play and I and I could I get
anxiety and and so sometimes while my
[ __ ] hotel room by myself I can't
turn it off like I can't [ __ ] calm
down it's part of the reason I drink on
the road like I don't think I've had a
legit
sober night sleep on the road like
unassisted possibly ever like because I
get into a hotel room and I start my
brain starts go crazy and when I was on
the road with travel channel I was doing
[ __ ] Ted 3 bucket list adventures a
day so I would I would swim with great
white sharks jump off the stadium and
rappel off table mountain and then get
back to my room after a couple of vodka
sodas and still be like [ __ ] wired I
just throw on I'm throwing anything I
mean so much [ __ ] I love Dan Carlin's
hardcore history oh yeah that thing
that's like I turn that on and I get
excited this is gonna sound weird but
you know how like when hurricanes coming
in and so you have to get bottled water
and canned food is that what you oh no I
get excited when hurricane coverage is
on the TV like or like big storm
coverage I go into my room and I get
excited like a warm blanket I go oh good
to her I don't know why it's a grounding
or something but I get excited like the
Florida people are out he's got a nice
fat I don't know that when they ever
hurricane coverage I just sit by the TV
all [ __ ] day and it makes me so happy
I [ __ ] but like like I said I said on
a podcast one time I said I said I don't
know who the [ __ ] I was talking to I was
talking to Danish an O'Neill and I said
the first wet dream I ever had I was
riding a horse hello this weekend i'm
doing this new bit called secret in the
middle of my show like it because I'm
not gonna finger secrets I'll think of
like things that are funny but are
interesting and so I go we got only
heard a secret let's do secret I'm and
then I said the first time ever a wet
dream I was riding a horse dudes were
losing their [ __ ] mind cuz they had
heard me saying on a podcast and it was
almost like it wasn't a laughter they
were getting up out of their chair going
[ __ ] [ __ ] i heard eww yes this is true
this just like it was like it's so weird
you know people people will come to me
and go you know I because my kids will
come in and out of the podcast all the
time and I talk very openly about Isla
and she's like my weirder up the two
kids and they're like yeah I'll go on
stage and they'll be like tell tell the
ILA tell the ILA story the tell georgia
midgets although i love story with the
toothbrush and you're like how do you
[ __ ] know that and they're like you
general your podcast I'm like holy [ __ ]
like I had a joke that happened on the
podcast that got it into my special
about our safe word but like it's really
crazy how the dialogue has changed
between I mean I don't think I sold a
ticket I don't think I sold one ticket
this week to someone who hadn't heard me
on my podcast really I don't think I
sold one I mean we I would it this
weekend got a little [ __ ] out of
control I you know I performed my shirt
off so then I told everyone they said
hey guys three dollar drinks upstairs if
you shirtless so everyone ended up
shirtless upstairs but it was and so I
do these big like meet and greets after
the shows and it was all podcast fans it
was all guys like going the podcast fans
like i did a tour through China a couple
years ago and basically there's no
there's like one full-time comedy club
in Shanghai and it's like a hundred and
twenty seat room so everything else is
just like a bar gig it's mostly like
American and English and Australian
expats but like I did this show in
Guangzhou China and people are coming up
going I like comedy film nerds I listen
you know people would show up they
bought our we have a book comedy film or
guide to movies and they've like I
bought this online and I need you to
sign it I'm like in the middle of China
and it's like it's crazy i don't have
the bit as big of a fan bases you so i
can't like pack a place but there's
always a handful of people who are like
you know all i drove three hours to come
see you and I'm like what like yeah it's
it's it's the coolest thing and it
wanted when it is packed full when we
have done like comedy film nerds live
and we pack it out it's the greatest
show like we've done live shows where we
just made fun of trailers we just show
trailers of movies coming up we pick
like six or seven and we'll pick like
one or two that are like cool something
that everyone's like all excited for and
everything else we try to find the
dumbest and it's a blast yeah where else
could you do that you
just show up and do that in a comedy
club without a following no you know to
me you couldn't just like come in and do
that the horse you know what dream bit
and the shirts are you know me people be
like yeah maybe maybe but like so how
much has your podcast change from the
first iteration of it and to where you
guys are now are you doing pretty much
the same thing well we started in
december of 09 okay i'm trying to think
what wouldn't i start mine no i haven't
been going that long that's eight years
yeah coming up 78 yes I mean they're so
good yeah my math is on number seven
seven years seven years that's a [ __ ]
long time what episode of you want three
of 50 something and then we've done
another 50 some spoiler app so we've
done over 400 episodes and that's once a
week yeah it's it started just hey let's
talk about movies and we didn't even
have guests and then we started bringing
on guests and then it's sort of the
format within the first six months or so
to a year kind of became now it's sort
of that's our format where we top of the
show we sort of what's talking what's
going on or I'll if I'm not on the road
as much anymore but when I was I would
at you know hey thanks everyone for
coming out to this show the show and
then we talk about because we record on
tues we record and release on Tuesday we
don't do a lot of editing so the reason
for that is we talk about movies that
just came out the weekend prior oh wow
so so what are you guys talking about
this week this week we'll be talking
about um guys are other news for words
right well that comes out next week so
we're doing about next one comes out the
16th did you get that I heard it's
[ __ ] amazing oh I can't wait I I'm
it's weird gonna do two episodes about
it like I can't the thing why I think
it's going to be great and this what I'm
getting from the trailers so a force
awakens which was fun it was great but
there are certain things they had to do
you know we gotta give chewy and Han and
seats we got to bring the gang back and
we got to hit these points rogue one
feels like let's just do something
awesome in the Star Wars universe let's
just blow it out we don't we have no
constraints yeah I it look
it looks fantastic to me I can't wait I
can't wait but you're gonna see it all
dude I'm gonna see two or three times I
mean it's like there's no two ways about
it and I think so yeah so there are
formats pretty much we talk about ways
it just came out and we focus on the
guests like if the guest is really into
westerns or they just made a movie like
whatever whatever they want to talk
about then we kind of go into you know
dvds and we now we started to talk about
movie trailers I'm obsessed with movie
trailers they're great i'm obsessed with
movie I'd like to a point where I think
I have a problem with it like I I one of
my favorite feeling so you know the
feeling you ever ever get done to
impress and you're in the elevator at
the hotel and you're getting at room and
then your brain goes I should I haven't
checked off yet today yeah like that's
that great like oh it's gonna be great
and I I do that with with trailers I go
oh my god I haven't looked at apple
trailers in like two weeks oh I bet
there's a whole new front page yeah I
get excited that today I did it today
and I was like other one anything really
great on today um but i watch the
trailer for Fast and Furious the new one
oh yeah that looks really [ __ ] good
those movies were Blatz I haven't seen
one of those since probably like the
second one oh they're insane they're
insane there's great number one
franchise oh yeah ever they're insane
the movies and now they just get bigger
and crazier and they're a blast I mean
it's just like they do these stunts that
are just so awesome they're like
ridiculously awesome that you just like
it's like an amusement park or the like
now we're going to spin you around
backwards and then you're gonna stop and
then go the other way and you're just
like yeah does he do it it was I saw the
trailer I was like I think I might watch
that I don't think i'ma go see that when
I'm on the road just follow for sure I'm
the kind of viewer who if you spend 50
million dollars on a movie it's not lost
on me like I get into it like if the
more money you spend the more i like the
movie like I'm that [ __ ] guy I am the
perfect window for Hollywood I'm the
same intelligence I'm not too smart to
figure out who Keyser Soze is you know
but I'm smart enough to figure out Bruce
Willis is a ghost like I'm not I like I
I men
good trailer what's the best trailer
you've seen recently the best trailer
I've seen recently as um will they keep
I mean that's hard to say cuz I kind of
watch so many i'll tell you the best
trailer I've ever seen the best trailer
I've ever seen let's be cops sounds so
silly the movie was not that good but
that trailer [ __ ] it got me I said I
am [ __ ] seeing this I that trailer
was so [ __ ] great cuz it was just
like like I got the whole concept really
quickly hey let's be Cosby's yeah i
loved it i was like i'm in i'm [ __ ]
i'm in i'm trying i'm now I'm gonna look
I want to see if apple trailers but like
the [ __ ] I'm trying to think of who what
trailers were out now I can't watch
scary trailers the scary trailers I mean
the mainstream horror movies are also
sort of the same they have a like a
cheap scare like a and then they they're
also the same pattern that some of the
coolest movies I've seen well all of the
rogue one trailers have been amazing to
me and each one I see is and it's rogue
one is kind of help flip me normally
when a big movie like that's coming out
like I don't want to see the trailers as
you don't want to I don't want to ruin
anything or file if i do see a trailer i
only want to see it on the big screen i
don't want to watch it on my phone or
laptop but now they keep releasing cool
[ __ ] that I get more more and more fired
up for so I'm trying to find a apple
trailers I'm gonna tell you which ones
okay i really liked I can't believe
they're doing another spider-man oh
that's the day of welken spider-man's
because Sony owns the rights to it and
there's a clause in there that if they
have to keep making movies if they let
it go past a certain amount of time then
they lose the rights to it that's why
they keep banging those out oh thank you
comedy film urge calm thank you the
comedian was a good trailer yes I like
that color on the fate of the Furious
was a good trailer oh I'll tell you it
was a really really good trailer what's
that movie where the kids break into the
blind guys house oh god what is that I
got to bring this up oh yeah that was
fantastic man that was
how could i forget the name of that that
was like all right i'll tell you a dumb
[ __ ] trailer fistfight now that
looked I'm like hey what [ __ ] movie
are we gonna make where grown men have
to fight each other you also can just go
home and not fight a human like what the
[ __ ] uh let's see I was awesome Tom
Cruise's the mummy looks good oh it
looks like I'm like all right Tom Cruise
you know it's like Jack Reacher finds
the mummy I'm in uh yeah I was like [ __ ]
yes uh let's see I haven't seen I am
like I need to catch up I am also like
it's so funny you really cut to the core
of me as a person on what I like and
dislike and where my phobias are on bio
trailer like immediately I become very
cynical I go [ __ ] that it's like a real
emperor like thumbs-up thumbs-down thing
where you go man this [ __ ] pass right
like I saw one trailer I'm sure it's on
here but it's like the cover of it is
two dudes holding each other's heads
like there I was like pass I was like
immediately the most homophobic guy in
the world no [ __ ] way I'm seeing that
[ __ ] or like this one says sing I don't
even know what it is I won't watch it
cuz I'm like yeah I don't think I like
sing I don't even know what it is so
much that what what is happening to with
train this is a fun game by the way just
going through a getting little [ __ ]
tank monster trucks pass because Smurfs
I'm definitely gonna see my kids want to
see it and in it and it's all about
finding other Smurfs uh anytime like it
really cuts also to the to the [ __ ]
answer of like you know Scarlett
Johansson got [ __ ] for playing a agen
woman leading role right and like and
like Matt Damon in the great wall china
movie yeah but I got to be honest with
you I don't want to sound like a dick
but like if I see a movie and it's
called it's called like the fast break
and it's
chestnut and most def and it's like five
bleeding black dudes ago and I think
that's marking the black people I'm
gonna pass or like before Christmas and
you see Danny Glover and Medea or
whatever I'm like that's market that's
meant for them like I don't watch them
but then if you put like if you if you
appropriate a culture and you put if you
make a movie and it's an leading Asian
actress that I've never heard of and
she's on the cover a lot of times I look
at it and I go oh I don't want to read
subtitles like but if I see Scarlett
Johansson there and it's called the
samurai go what's this you know like
Hollywood's just doing it cuz that's why
our brains think that's what you you
know that it's who how many how many
people watched up how to lose it how to
be a man think like a man all right not
a lot of white people right you know but
it's just it's a book Think Like a Man
wrong man why wouldn't I enjoy it oh cuz
it's got nine black leads oh ok oh and
Gary Owen and do you know I love Gary
Owen I'm not [ __ ] on the movie I'm
just saying that that is how they market
these movies you gotta put a [ __ ]
someone don't worry where you go I'll do
that I'll go that take my money I want
to see that I think in certain in
certain cases they go well like Tyler
Perry started making movies for a very
underserved section of the marketplace
like middle-aged black women no one was
making movies for them and he went I
will and so they're just like great and
he goes and they weren't going to the
movies and now they are to see his stuff
and it's like it's awesome in some cases
though boy we talked about on Comedy
filmers we call it trailer side well
they'll take a good movie and they'll
make a trailer that's that either makes
it look dumb or they reveal too much of
it you watch the trailer and you go oh I
know what's going to happen now that
guy's the criminal that's oh that just
happened in one the other day that I saw
where they're like where I think the guy
dies in the trailer right that's just
sick okay I guess you know what happens
in this movie well like that new
Jennifer Lawrence crisp at Phil Pratt
Pratt film passengers looks interesting
and then you know so they set the
premise all we woke up on this on the
space station early yeah oh wow and then
you hear this voice over towards the end
of the trailer
goes actually it wasn't a mistake and
you're just like oh well now we know
that we're why is he going off the space
yeah it's on fire I know it doesn't cool
them swimming if there is cool [ __ ] in
there and it's a it's a significant film
in the sense that this is what she got
way more money than he did so women
leading ladies have always gotten
underpaid this is one of the first times
where it's like no no this is a Jennifer
Lawrence movie and she got some crazy
like 23 million and he got like 10 or
something like that and it was like I
didn't know that it's a big it's a big
deal because it's it's they're finally
going well she has proven through um you
know whatever the hunger games movies
and then undone all these Oscar films
that it's like Jennifer Lawrence can
open a movie I'll go watch her in office
[ __ ] yeah i watch her cold bones was
that it ah winter bone winter bones that
was that was her breakout film [ __ ]
amazing she was like 6 17 or 18 or
something during that movie Chris Pratt
Chris Pratt is I think he's good but you
know but you're right i mean i hope you
don't take this as a fence Chris Pratt
so I know you listen to my podcast but
but but I you could have plugged eight
dudes into that role eight dudes I know
20 if we want to pay him more than her
right but there's only one Jennifer
Lawrence I know and you and she [ __ ]
that girl's bad ah I love Chris Pratt
like guardians of the galaxy he's great
guardians of the galaxy oh there's
another there's a great trailer that
trailer guardians galaxy two I haven't
seen it oh dude oh wait yes I have dude
uh wait where does is it with a little
gadelle things carrying a bomb or
something yeah yeah i saw the food it's
guys gonna watch them hammered that and
so i can't remember but like Gardens the
galaxy is is that now it's I guess we're
calling it a franchise since there's two
but that's where I'd go well that's
Chris Pratt yeah he is there are some
guys that could maybe do that but he's
making it very much his role but
passengers you go Jennifer Lawrence in
space with civilian bode yeah yeah I
know it was
it is so funny as I for the first maybe
I watched you try watch trailers over
and over again or I'll go back to the
thing and see if they come up with a
second trailer i miss understood the
line where he says we woke up 90 years
too early right I thought he said nine
and I was like who gives a [ __ ] pissing
chill hang out [ __ ] wait till you mean
it's 20 25 whatever 2016 what's the
[ __ ] difference nine years early this
is it so you'll be 30 when they're 20
okay like that would be awesome if that
was the premise nine years early uh you
know I don't know cup a day earlier than
them what are we gonna do it um all the
technology is basically the same I could
I I could I could just watch trailers
although would stuff I sometimes i love
when i go on when i go on youtube and i
see a new trailer for something i
haven't seen and then I'm like oh here
we go dude I I have an apple TV at home
I don't have cable anymore yeah so I
just go to the trailer button i dunno my
daughters are the [ __ ] problem my
daughter's just gotta just bought him a
[ __ ] TV and I said let's put the
directv in your room and they're like
now now I go what I'm gonna watch that
anyway dad if we want we'll just come
living room and watch it I said what we
want they wouldn't just have him hook up
the wii and we'll just watch things off
up amazon and and [ __ ] for whatever
that other one is natalie's like
fantastic beasts is a good trailer kong
skull island is that one looks awesome
[ __ ] that looks good that one looks
great i'm excited for that because the
peter jackson kong movie I did not like
it was turned black yes too long he it
was like three hours or something like
that there was some cool stuff but Peter
Jackson movies in my opinion get way too
long Koncz call island though looks like
awesome yeah it looks really [ __ ]
good um the bad kids of crest ville I'll
see that I haven't seen that um it's
just it's just these kids that are bad
kids and then it turns out the teachers
want to kill them i get i can get into
really cheesy [ __ ] movies very easy I
gotta say like I would not when I first
saw the trailer for collateral beauty
which also comes out next week go with
that one that's Will Smith I won't watch
really will watch it makes me sad it all
while yeah it looks I was one of those
movies are when I bet you this is cheesy
but um I bet it's the kind of cheesy
that I want to go watch alone cuz i know
i'll cry like it's a movie while I'm
like if I was on the road and the other
comic goes all you wanna go see that
alegna I got some stuff to do today then
I go see it alone and sit up in the
corner and cry I cried at mallanna oh
that's awesome i heard the lot is great
man I credit mawana when the grandmas
showed up just for you buddy oh dude
have you ever i got i wish i had i wish
i had this is why I'd want an assistant
i'd love go hey pull this clip up and
show you this i went and did there's a
movie that everyone knows the movie i'm
talking about right now if you've
podcast fan but uh there's a movie that
I cannot watch or I'll cry time
travelers wife so I go in and I do
Opie's show Opie radio it's me and
Sharad nopee and i tell him i said yeah
i watch if I watched the end of time
travelers wife all I will start crying
and he's like no Opie like well I mean I
mean this out of respect was like
old-school shock jacory right and he's
like let's get it let's do it put it up
there let's see him cry you didn't
realize I was really gonna [ __ ] cry
and I think I made him very
uncomfortable and there's video its
online of me sobbing uncontrollably
watching the end of the time travelers
wife but that movie man [ __ ] dude I
cried when I read the book time
travelers wife and then I cried when I
saw the movie he really taught himself
to jack off in the book uh yeah that's
fun crazy the book heights they're two
different medium so it's always a good
wasn't leaving anything like the book
like okay fine the movie did a decent
job the book is awesome i mean the book
was like really interesting oh maybe i
should read it and i think it would it
was written by it had the woman had to
have written it like who dated a much
older man or something like that cuz my
girlfriend's a lot younger than me and
so you're always doing that like i'll be
like oh and i do this bit in my act of
like you know when you date someone a
lot younger than you and you say you
tell him a story oh i did this they go
oh yeah that was when i was six and
you're like okay well go ask your dad uh
you know I always
I always reference it by do you remember
communism like that's what people go huh
like I whenever you talk to anyone in
the audience you go like you can't
there's if people don't remember what it
was like no old are you I'm 47 ochem 44
yeah i can't i have a hard time talking
to like 20 year olds because we have
done nothing similar right like with a
totally different lives yeah i got a
computer in the internet when I was 25
yeah I was 25 when I got my first
computer and I had AOL I was 21 yeah I
was 21 when I got my first computer and
I had prodigy yeah yeah and I didn't
even understand I was like I really
couldn't wrap my head around what the
internet would do I was like so wait
you're telling me i basically can get
sporting lines here like them betting
lines I was like that's it so we she's
got betting lines and then generally you
want to see what the weather's like in
Alaska you clicking you're like oh it's
kinda interesting and then I remember
getting and then I don't even know if I
even sat in front of it for longer than
five minutes until i moved to new york
and when I moved to New York in 1997-98
and that's like 98 99 that's when I was
like oh you can get porn off here and I
was like that's what i'll be doing for
the rest of my life and then and that
was when i got i got really into the
into using a computer but I was like Phi
was 26 years old yeah that if you're you
know under the age of 30 you've probably
had access to the internet since you
were about eight or nine oh my daughters
have Joey Diaz is calling I can't 30 go
yet i had the same manager motive
special real quick yeah Joey I'm doing a
podcast hey I watched your special last
night [ __ ] amazing Joey hope we use
whoa you colin kaepernick cat caprica I
was [ __ ] a howling [ __ ] laughing
Joey Kopernik copernica Nick all right
brother I'll talk to you later Coco uh
Joey Diaz and specials on C so I don't
need to tell you this everyone knows
this is listening but if used a code
word Joey like I did last night you can
get a free month free trial I have a
show on seeso too but I don't know the
word for that Joey Diaz man he and i had
the same manager when we first lived in
la 20 years ago really and so we met
doing all these like showcases together
and you know he's just like a he's like
a dude you have like war stories with
you know like I use the best cocoa is is
the wait where did you start did you
start stand up in Chicago actually
started i was a freshman at the
University of Arizona in Tucson Arizona
I was 18 years old and I hold on did you
start at the tempe improv uh no i
started at laughs in tucson Oh Tucson oh
yeah yeah and the first comedy show I
ever did was a u.s. college comedy
competition it was sponsored by Doritos
and a defunct gum company called stick
'let's and if you go to my youtube
channel which I barely update but
youtube.com slash grandma what I think
you'll see the very first time ever did
stand up the MC was a young comedian by
the name of Judd Apatow and you can see
him in 1988 with acid wash jeans and a
mullet shut oh yeah he was the emcee and
how [ __ ] crazy I did I did the show
in like shorts you know like plaid
shorts and like flip-flops or something
this and then didn't-didn't went how
soon until you moved to LA so I I
started in college and I was in a sketch
group and then I graduated 91 and moved
back to Chicago where I'm originally
from yeah and that's where I started
working as a professional like that's
where I started during zanies and all
the clubs and that's where I met like
Jimmy Pardo and Mike Schmidt and Paul
Gilmartin and all those comics that's
[ __ ] the what what a generation
Chicago is generational there's like
chunks yeah it's almost like it's almost
like a like a flood like a like a flood
damn progressing and all sudden like
it'll build up with talent and then all
of a sudden the comedy is run by Chicago
comics yeah really interesting it was
such a scene when i was there in the
earth so i graduated college 91 so in
the early 90s there was like 15 or some
full-time comedy clubs in the chicago
area i'm trying to find your first time
doing stand-up ah so I wait I was
waiting tables but I quit that job in
less than
year because you could within a six hour
drive of Chicago you could fill your
calendar really oh yeah dude every
Milwaukee Evansville Indiana like every
little mid-sized town and then every
little bar gig you could fill your
calendar really oh yeah I mean I was not
making crazy money but I was like in my
20s had an apartment in Chicago you know
had like a Toyota Tercel that got you
know 30-some miles to the gallon I'm
gonna find this is it one of the first
videos you put what I think so god damn
you got a lot of videos I don't know
what you're talking about I just don't
update it frequently as i want to start
doing it though I want to start doing
more political stuff on my youtube
channel because i like i like my youtube
channel but i've been putting more stuff
on instagram lately oh nice i just
haven't been on the road as much because
i was doing like 30 40 weeks a year for
a while and then earbuds took a lot of
time and I was focused on that it's so
good man thanks to you guys what did you
guys shoot it with a 5d yeah yeah yeah i
love i love the 5d it was and we got
this young camera crew these young guys
that were super hungry that had enough
experience they know what they're doing
but like weren't overpriced yeah because
i told i was like look guys if this
happens if with the crowdfunding happens
we're gonna go on the road i'm gonna put
four of you in a hotel room ok you know
it's gonna be subway sandwiches is going
to be your meal like it's not you know
and they were like we're in cuz they're
all like it was a step up for all of
them they're like either assistant
cameras or an assistant DP and this
would make them full DP full camera ops
and stuff like that and they were
awesome it was such a like I felt like I
was the coach of like a bat of team were
they podcast fans of themselves some of
them were and they started to really
learn about the podcast community and we
you know we we had a tight schedule I
mean we raised 140 gram which is great
that's not a lot of money to make a film
you know it isn't I mean it's the most
money I was ever in charge of but it
still wasn't a lot so we had to like and
I did all the booking cuz I a comic I
know how to book you know it's so I was
like we're flying in here we're doing
these interviews were getting a rental
car blah blah blah that was really cool
and all the podcasters
who just opened up their homes or their
studios or whatever to interview it was
that I mean the podcast community made
that movie they raised the money on
Kickstarter and then we're way you've
been you've been like cut I mean oh this
this will be like grandiose terms but
kind of you have kind of created the
community a tad bit yeah with the
festival i would i would say that
festivals i mean i remember when at
first when you guys first started doing
it I wanted to be a part of it so bad
and then this last year I think you
asked me to do it I was like you're on
the road yeah I mad but that's been the
coolest [ __ ] thing is when you hear
one of your favorite podcasts at that
festival and you'd be like oh [ __ ] man I
would love to go to this place we love
to go to it we want we were we've been
trying to get you in for a couple of
years now it's just you're a road dog so
your dates same with Diaz I've been
trying to get him to do it yeah um but
like we will we'll get you in and you'll
see how when you're there since you're
such a podcast fan oh yeah and you have
such great following you're gonna see
the community it I love it it's the
coolest thing it's one of the coolest
things one of the hardest things in
podcasting is to break is to like break
new talent to your friends to your fans
like to go this is someone that I love I
think you should start checking out
their [ __ ] and then once it happens you
see it happening you're like oh wow
that's really cool and it's like it but
it's same with me like going and doing
like I did Chris Hardwick's podcast a
long time ago and I don't think um I
don't think like I don't heed like I
don't think it was received well like he
didn't even like tweet it out that the
other he just released it and was like
didn't like when like hey guys new
podcast today I was like looking for it
and it just what came out one day just
like put like almost like he was like
all right we put it up that way I did
what I said I do and and I was like oh
that would have been cool to get fans
from next but I think that's a different
type of fan like you know like you know
it's weird that the and this is such a
thing we wrestle with every year with
the festival in terms of programming is
what fan base is overlap and what ones
don't that's an interesting question
so okay so let's see who do you think
overlaps I think I one of the most
interesting podcasts out there right now
is my favorite murder oh my god they
were great at the festival we had him in
for the first year it was and it was
also talk about get festive all I listed
them talk about doing the festival that
podcast is really fun to listen to and
I've been given george's number and i
want to text her and tell her i like it
how much i like it but uh but i haven't
sounds like that's where I'm a married
man I don't want you know if I run into
her I'll say something but that's an
interesting I feel like those people
came from out and those fans came from
out of nowhere well they had if i'm not
mistaken well if they did several things
first they just tapped into the fact
that like any of those like murder TV
show reality TV shows are women for
whatever reason women love them my wife
loves it yes women love I told my wife I
go you'll love this [ __ ] podcast my
wife's just got into podcasting she just
started pot listen to podcast and I'd
watch her walk around with her ear buds
in walk around the house and you be like
that LeAnn it's like huh what what I'm
in the middle of something more
listening something and I'd be like hey
you listen to a podcast like a [ __ ]
nerd like that's not how you're supposed
to do it like good god what the [ __ ]
wrong with you walking around the house
and not interacting with people I was
like do it by yourself we don't listen
to podcast when you're with other people
like she would do it like we were on a
car i just put her head sets in and I
was like what can we listen to it
together and she was like well yeah but
I'm in the middle I don't have to start
it over for you I'm like the [ __ ] but uh
but yeah that that I think people who
listen to WTF probably like uh like
Nerdist like like the there's a genre of
podcast that I Paula Tompkins yeah like
that i don't i mean i don't so that
won't cuz paul hates me but but i like
there's like those are these there's
like I would say doug loves movies' fans
like those too like they like the paw of
tompkins well it's interesting and a lot
of it is like obviously its guests
driven so I've been on never not funny a
lot so I've never been never not funny
Jimmy and I talked about it a few times
we've lived next to each other near each
other that seemed at ralphs all the time
is if we gotta get John I was like
definitely and I text back and forth
there
but I've never grown Todd's either Todd
glass oh wow I'm Todd and I like time
I've talked about it a lot Todd show I'm
on Todd's a lot like I'd love to have
you on Comedy filmers I think there's
there's little and I don't want to use
the wrong word here to make it sound but
there's little like clicks yeah clicks
is or just yeah I don't not with us it's
not with us but it is also but like the
road of the rogan world I mean it's I
think it's just different worlds I don't
know that even use click so like the
like I've never been on Joe Rogan I've
never been this is my first time on this
one I've been on Redman a lot i know him
i was on Sam tripolis a fair amount yeah
but like I'm not that plugged into that
world part of it is I'm not a Comedy
Store comic I perform at the hollywood
improv so i don't get sets at the comedy
store so i wonder if our podcasts or
break broken up by kali clubs i think it
has something to do with it it does
because you think about it like Nerdist
meltdown and UCB are totally different
genres like I'm like one of the reasons
I'm known Todd glass for so long I've
worked the improv with him on the road
yeah like the hollywood improv vegas
improv God's fans are I'd be interested
to know who Todd's fans are our who
Todd's listeners are because that
podcast one of my favorite podcast in
the world i love it i love i do
characters on that pod car i love that
but there they want he had one podcast
that I it's like you know that you have
moments where you listen to a podcast
and it you'll never forget where you
were cuz you laughed so hard yeah like I
remember being in a hotel room one time
in denver and zach galifianakis was
telling Chris Hardwick that him his
brothers taking mushrooms and gone to
the yeah the Getty and Zach said I
thought the sign said why shouldn't you
touch the marble haha I woke up like I
was like half in and out and I got up
out of bed laughing I was laugh as hard
but Todd and Rory Rory Scovel is ma is
is might be the funniest [ __ ] human
being that's ever walked this planet he
haven't Todd did this thing with the the
red fox dunt dunt bana Gary hear that
yeah where they red fox the stories red
fox
came out to stage it was dun dun dunna
and he goes I performed for six people
and started walking off in the band
played the music dun dun Donna right
again they did that over and over again
as different characters as Jerry
Seinfeld and I was on a train in
Brussels going to Amsterdam and I was
doubled [ __ ] over going MIT please
don't let this ever end I one of my
favorite episodes to ever have been a
part of was the episode I was on with
Todd glass where we played the luminaire
song ho hey I've been trying to do the
right but where he got a clip they did
it on Jimmy Fallon with chickens
clucking blah blah so Todd kept playing
it on this episode and then towards the
end he just let it play for a half an
hour and everyone in the his studio just
clocked along with it he it was like it
was such a surreal amazing moment where
else could you do that he took he took
podcasting I think he I think he
forwarded the art of podcasting Oh more
than any one individual because when
when he you know he was doing that show
with jimmy dore comedy everything else
which was cool and they were they were
kind of a good pairing and when Todd
started his own thing the first time I
did it I went oh this is the purest form
of Todd glass that's what I it is it was
like he does he's got a bubble machine
and lights audio podcast he's all about
the lighting in the moon and everything
is everything is is he's painted imagery
of something that I don't know if it's
real or not and like almost like a phil
hendrie kind of way right thing I really
don't know if he did the show above an
exotic car museum like I didn't know and
I would I and legs other kid across the
hall with the [ __ ] music and the
saxophone and you'd be like wait it's
like a fry the first time it happened I
want you [ __ ] wait hold on are you
like it was like it was like real
theater of the mind oh it's I told him I
told him I ended up doing it as a gag
but I said you know what you should do
Todd do it podcast do a live show
but do in the dark cut the house lights
off and do it in the dark cuz that's how
we listen to your podcast it's theater
the mind right doing the dark that Todd
was like I think that hard I'm serving
drinks yeah okay sweet let's go out on
your I could do this I could do this all
day uh one of the greatest podcasts ever
ever out there ever was comedy and
everything else Jim with jimmy dore
jimmy dore when he interviewed Kyle sees
oh man it was like and they held him
like that was intense dude it was that
but that was like like that she should
have gotten the Grammy right whatever
the Emmy because i was on a car ride
from San Sacramento driving down and it
was a two-parter cuz I think he came
back the next week and I'd gotten both
of my talk I run in someone they'd go
whoa whoa whoa whoa you haven't heard
the car seats podcast i was like no
[ __ ] that was an amazing podcast
yeah that was an amazing podcast I mean
like defend yourself you're kind of
exploiting young comedians defend it and
it was like it was it was it was like it
was almost like good journalism you know
what I mean because it was like that's a
thing that that if you're not in the
comedy community you might not know and
a lot of us feel like I mean I
definitely feel like the comedy class
thing is kind of nonsense you got to
just go on stage and do it I understand
there's some people that need that class
structure to help sure like to get their
foot in the door oh now i can now that's
how i can get on stage well I get it but
I would never recommend to take your
class no just write some jokes girl on
stage if you don't have the balls to
just write strokes and get on stage and
you shouldn't be a comedian yeah i agree
with that one hundred percent like that
man that there was at that period where
Kyle came where Kyle was doing that and
putting it on my spaces around yeah I
remember Tom screws at my house having
dinner and he walked in and he walked
right over my computer he's like tell me
you haven't seen this yet I go what he
goes Kyle sees I won't know anyone
you're gonna love this and then clicked
the [ __ ] trailer and the the you know
the class and I was like what the [ __ ]
is this and he's like this only gets
better have you not read this letter
from don t know
I was like no Negro you're gonna have to
because I think I should probably just
go home now and I was like oh my [ __ ]
god that was like god damn it you think
about that like uh I hosted a bunch of
game shows I could have made a killing
teaching hosting classes how to read
teleprompter how to bump out to
commercial I could have like a dollar
show one of the one of the things that
they don't ever tell you but it really
helps sell the show is you have one
moment where you get up off the couch
you like hot damn it that goes in a
trailer it's like a little buzz moment
yeah there's so you could teach a class
about hosting I could I could have made
a killing but I would have hated myself
I mean taking money for people you know
we're just gonna fail yeah real people
hostess groton host right already know
and so I was like so uh yeah I want to
do it now you just made me think of an
idea I want to do a documentary on me
about you know like people go you do a
documentary about a comic but do a
documentary about a host who just can't
stop posting and I'm like going into
starbucks I'm like welcome to start like
everything is a host read with it with a
choice of three drip coffees thank you
I'm Bert Kreischer i think i'll take the
like just can't get out of his [ __ ]
way hosting I have been taking general
meetings with networks this past month
and I think I'm i think i am not selling
myself as a host because I go yeah I
don't do [ __ ] reads I go hostings
changed you look at the internet yeah
it's what's what blows me away so much
is like all these kids pretended they
wanted to do something different on the
internet in YouTube they're just doing
exactly what television shows were doing
with these fake prank shows and fake
prank fake social experiments and so
many [ __ ] Casey nice status I love Katie
nice that he's one of my favorite guys
to watch bum that his vlog one away but
it was like such a ego-driven [ __ ]
jack off fest we were like good god
Casey like go back to showing me how to
organize an office but like but yeah I
yeah I that's why i love podcasters I
don't like I get pissed off when someone
gets into podcasting and they they don't
understand the medium
respect it yeah like we've had and we've
dealt with this at the festival
sometimes sometimes it's like a big name
celebrity who gets into it and they're
not getting into it for the right
reasons they're not getting into because
it's like I need this freedom of
expression they're getting it into it
cuz norm pattis brought a bit yeah
exactly exactly or there or there yet
the manager when you need to podcast and
they don't understand they don't respect
it we've had some giant named people at
LA pod fest they had 14 people in their
room no one no one came to their show
and they they're technically a bigger
star yeah but then then jimmy pardo but
Jimmy Pardo's room is packed what do you
think about Anna Faris's podcast have
you listened to it I have a little bit
and I think she's doing it the right way
but why by putting out putting
everything cutting everything in half so
she gets double the numbers and get
something well he's doing I doubt figure
it out as you if you just say this was
30 minutes and there's another 1 30
minutes they're gonna download both
right they will hear the whole [ __ ]
interview and you get double the
downloads so you're on the top of the
charts that's smart it's cheating Anna
someone tell Anna this I love you Anna I
think you're amazing I should i respond
and yeah I've already shop [ __ ] on the
whole family today I think you're
fantastic but put one episode up I want
to know how good you really are I can't
measure myself based on your [ __ ]
unqualified [ __ ] standings well that
whatever I mean I I applaud anyone
that's finding a way to jump their
numbers out yeah god Bless You me too I
what do you think about her podcast
though I think it's like you know she
seems like she's doing it for the right
reasons of someone of that state like
her and her husband don't need yeah add
read money from their podcast so why do
it she's doing as she wants to have that
expression she wants to have that outlet
and that I give you respect for because
you know this we all know this from
traditional media is very structured you
have to be this you have to be that
traditional media you know they give you
the TV show they give you the part in
the movie they give you the money for
the film which means they can take it
away yeah we've all had shows cancelled
you know everyone I've ever done right
exactly and I've done over 300 episodes
of TV
and nobody you know NBC's not canceling
LA pod fest no one's canceling my
podcast no one's canceling this no one's
coming here and shutting down the man
cave it ain't [ __ ] happening no ear
buds we're we we look we did festivals
and word you know we look for regular
distribution but we knew it needs to be
on netflix it will be it will be we knew
eventually well if we don't get a good
deal we don't have to sign a shitty
distribution deal we can sell it on our
own website which we've been doing and
then we knew we did the research we can
get it on iTunes and Amazon and Netflix
and we'll just roll it out like we were
a big [ __ ] studio yeah and no one is
no one is telling us how to do it or no
one is getting in the way or preventing
us or whatever wits our movie and we're
selling it our way and it's it's the
greatest its aggressive it's the best
feeling you know is one of the things
that I connected with probably most in
this was that Adam Carolla I heard him
reference this is my pirate ship I get
to do with it what I want and it's it is
being as being black beard and taking
your pirate ship wherever you want to go
in the open seas you make your own
[ __ ] rules yeah as if I want to do
these stupid silly character-driven
reads at the plane i'll do it if i want
to write a song and make fun of Tom
Segura I'll put on my podcast if I have
a weird interaction from stage I'll pull
it put it on my podcast this is my thing
I get to do whatever the [ __ ] I want
it's like it's one of the things like
like my buddy does the show hot ones
ever seen it it's really great Sean
Evans he's my buddy through the show
obviously but I'm a big fan of the show
I did it and then someone some show and
Australia stole his idea basically we 10
progressively hotter wings the last ones
[ __ ] ask you questions and your
mouth's on fire as you're trying to
answer them praying so they really catch
you off guard like you do end up saying
stuff you didn't plan on saying right
he's like I don't know man I talk [ __ ]
sometimes he's like oh great so they
show stole it and I was like [ __ ] I'm
gonna call have Sean call in to my
podcast and talk about this thievery
getting i'm posting it today and we're
gonna [ __ ] in so I grabbed my Eleanor
Kerrigan episode I have Sean call I
posted immediately and a me
it's taken down all the [ __ ] sites
this other shows taken down they don't
do anymore and you're like [ __ ] yes
really the goddamn troops it's it's I
mean look what look what you can do you
can do I mean you know Marc Maron and
Adam Carolla and some of those guys
fought the trolling people they've got
them and they dig essentially one I mean
it sounds like it's still sort of in
flux but they basically beat those guys
down did you go did you go to them to
the [ __ ] superhero meeting at Adam
Carolla's house that night now did you
hear about it uh-huh red band when he
told me about it basically it was all
the top podcasters in the country at
Adam Carolla's house to figure out how
they're gonna [ __ ] fight this patent
troll like brogan marin corolla just
[ __ ] everyone I heard yeah that Marin
talk about it we interviewed him for the
doc and he said that like Hardwick i
think was there too and and you're like
whoa [ __ ] man that's a lotta what are
the top podcasts I guess it's gonna be
corolla the top comedy wants oh yeah I
don't look I don't listen any other one
because just so you know the NPR shows
are doing millions of downloads in
episode yes however uh by the way
coolest moment of podcasting ever
probably I get an email from a woman who
loves Muppet lives in my podcast big fan
of your podcast loved your book by the
way my husband's got a podcast called
This American Life if you want to i'd
love to hang out this weekend and maybe
with human government one of your shows
hanging out in the green room in New
York with ira glass and uh need and
we're just bullshitting and talking
about like it was [ __ ] and we're
talking about podcasting we're talking
about numbers we're talking about like
advertising me and I'm like holy [ __ ]
those NPR shows are making crazy money
yeah I wonder oh yeah those those I mean
this american life is possibly one of
the greatest pieces of entertainment
that is ever being published anywhere on
a weekly basis it's what they're doing
it and great you can say hey they
brought their NPR you know terrestrial
radio audience to okay great
but now they've gotten this whole and
it's a whole if that's another separate
world like the people that I think
obviously there's some people that
listen to comedy podcast a definite
listen to the NPR ones too but the NPR
world kinda has its own its own in
freakonomics yeah those show it's a
different type of a that's my wife was
the [ __ ] what is the one was one
about the murder the [ __ ] Oh cereal
cereal that's the one that got my wife
those wifeless is NPR and then you
should check out 0 and then she started
us in the cereal and then she was like
Marin's got a lot of the crossover ya
maraan and NPR the same group I take
corolla I don't think he shares fans
with Joe I don't think Joan corolla have
the same fan base I think they're very
different yeah fan bases i think i think
well corolla just brought over his radio
people a lot of them and then he
cultivated that because his radio show
went off the air and he just said ok
come over here and download it and so he
he kept a lot of those people that he
had sort of been cultivating from like
the man show then the radio and
everything else like that and i think it
you know some of the coral it's weird
like I was just on you know his wife and
stephanie wylde are tailored to that
show for crying out loud which is a
parenting show their two women to talk
about having kids and parents and stuff
like that well his wife yeah she is
[ __ ] beautiful yeah it's dude [ __ ]
one of the things makes me more angry
than anything I saw a picture of him and
his family for like some going out to
the Christmas party and I was like his
wife is [ __ ] gorgeous like gorgeous
like I think I even told him that when I
had him on my podcast and I was like
well but I was like your wife is really
pretty like yeah yeah you know his wife
is gorgeous but you did to her Brian
broadcast yeah did her in Stephanie
while the Toyotas for crying out loud
and you know they're sort of it's
interesting because they're part of the
corolla network but then their show was
mostly listened to by women where I
would say his fan base is primarily male
you know but it's so interesting where
the fan base has come from how people
find your show what overlaps what
doesn't it's really you know obviously
we got a lot of fans because I I was a
guest a lot on Doug loves movies I you
know I wonder I don't think I
ever like I do Doug loves movies a lot
and I've probably had a couple of them
more I definitely have one of the most
epic doug loves movies ever where me and
him got in that fight and it was [ __ ]
insane thank God he put a bunny paywall
because if you give him gone out to
everyone my Twitter when was this i
don't even wonder this happen you've
heard about this huh well maybe i
shouldn't say anything we we were in st.
Louis and I came in off a flight and I
was definitely drunk but I wasn't like
drunk out of control but I was just
buzzed right I came in with 200
cheeseburgers and i was like i just
bought 200 cheeseburgers or hundred
cheeseburger no cheeseburgers i walked
him i was like i'm gonna bring him on
the stage it'll be my whatever I don't
know it Doug was like I don't want you
doing it and I didn't hear him say it at
all and so he brought me out I walked
out with cheeseburgers and as I said it
in what you're doing this and then he
brought him in and then I went back and
got him back out and then he and went
back and forth and then and I and then I
[ __ ] in and then I got him again and he
he said walked offstage he was like I'm
trying to be fair and balanced about
this cuz I definitely i shamed Torres
told me he's like you were a little out
of control so Doug's like no and he just
walks off stage and then I was like I'm
gonna go get him so I go to the green
room and he's clearly upset like he's
not it's not a joke and I'm like okay I
[ __ ] up he goes back on stage I'm like
maybe I should just leave then I go or
maybe I'll just walk through the
showroom with my shirt off and so I
walked through the showroom my shirt off
and Doug [ __ ] loses it on me and it
is and it's very [ __ ] real when did
this happen is probably four months ago
Wow let's go I've done but I've done
Doug loves movies since and Doug and I
Doug and I did a podcast on my uppers on
my podcast we released a podcast the
next day in my hotel room of us talking
about whether or not we could still be
friends it's one of my more downloaded
episodes because it's very real wow it's
racing there's no podcast to it it's
just the [ __ ] out the surround Mike
and it's just me and him going like you
as I was really [ __ ] intense it's a
really intense episode because we're
being very real and I I did not know
what was making up is that he I didn't I
explained to him what I like about Doug
loves movies and it's not the gameplay I
like right [ __ ] around in the beginning
and I go I don't even listen the game
dog like I turned it off at the game and
he was like he goes yeah be there are
people that like the game and I was like
yeah I know but when I'm on the show
like I like the chaos and he's like some
people hate the [ __ ] chaos and I was
like it's great but then he goes I'm
gonna put it behind a paywall so that I
he goes I don't want just people being
able to download it anywhere I mean it
by the way just get I i I'm not saying
this to my fans don't if you're my fan
don't [ __ ] listen to it he may hate
me but you would like you would be
fascinated by this episode well I yeah I
was on the road with a guy for a while
so I have my own uh yeah I've had my own
arguments with him on an off stage so
part of me might I don't know part of me
might be like yeah Burt go for it i
don't know like you know so yeah I don't
know where I'm releasing this I might
release this tomorrow but I'm gonna see
Doug again very soon and do it again I
like doing Doug loves movies it splits a
blast you know I don't do it as much as
I used to but so it makes it even more
fun now when I do it I like doing it I
like doing it I like when we do it on
the road yeah when I'm on the road and
he's on the road we meet up i like those
those are fun but um but yeah that those
pot those are like I don't think I've
ever pulled anyone from that group over
to my podcast it's a specific group you
know that's it's interesting like that
you want to talk about crossover this is
an interesting thing so like what I was
on the road with him for a long time and
um I didn't get the is big of a
following as I thought I would because
I'm not a stoner like I'm sober and so
the stoners would think I was funny they
left my SAT someone would even buy my
merge we did we did San Francisco to go
yes we did San Francisco together so
like what
I open for him as a stand up and doing
Douglas movie so the stance so his
audiences were always filled with
stoners and film people what did we do
DC together for Douglas movies one time
no we did I we did another city i canna
where wasn't DC maybe was I can remember
we did somewhere to get you you were you
were in you're engaged super high me in
yeah and um the high road and I road
yeah um but there's a great example so
I'm I co-star with him basically in the
end you know he's the star time the
co-star of the high road yeah and um it
wasn't like because it's a stoner thing
I'm funny in it i mean i'm in a giant
chunk of that movie I didn't like I have
18,000 Twitter followers you would think
all those years being on the road with
dog I would have a hundred thousand like
I look at like like the rogan guys all
you guys re and that's broad Ian's a
very interesting statement that is what
you're saying is really fascinating
because there is a massive crossover
when you when you are on Joe's podcast
right those guys go immediately and
subscribe to your podcast it's
interesting so I didn't get those
numbers I think part of it was the
stoner and then when i was on doug loves
movies' now we did comedy film nerds did
get a fair amount of his listeners
because that would be that'll be it's
right up their alley perfect cross over
yeah but like sometimes on doug loves
movies' it sort of adversarial and now
part of that is the performance of it
like your podcast should be immediately
crossover ability because like i would
imagine listening this podcast that
anyone's like oh [ __ ] i love movies I
want to [ __ ] right let this will be
really fun hearing two guys break down
what the movies i saw that weekend yeah
you would think but i noticed too with
Doug's podcast is the only podcast where
every time i do it just about not almost
not every time but most i would say
seventy percent of the time i'll get
people that say oh I love having grandma
went on and I'll always get a couple
like [ __ ] you i hate i listening to you
yeah it's
the only podcast where I've heard that I
know where else do I hear that it's a
very it's a very peculiar things really
interesting I get some people who when
I'm announced they they cheer they make
you know when I was on the road a lot
they put my name and the name tags but
then there was some people part of it is
like I would do this whistling thing
that made Doug mad and it would like
Pierce people's ears so that would piss
people off but like um and then if I
would Doug Benson's was an interesting
[ __ ] guy it was so innocent and then
when he started doing when he started
doing the yeah and then part of it is
like quasi because I you know and when
following sort of watching the rogan
world rogan himself is a very like hey
support this guy go to his show on the
road Brody told me it helped with his
ticket sales and all this stuff Doug
parks got an open door policy with his
friends like like when my specials
coming out Joe's like of course dude one
of the coolest most heartwarming things
ever we do the end of the world podcast
which is probably one of the biggest
things I've ever been a attached to ever
me bill burr Stanhope and Rogan and
Fitzsimmons on stage and the first words
out of Joe's mouth when the show starts
ladies and gentlemen the Machine his
hour special airs this was friday on
showtime in november 11 to 10pm make
sure to check it out the first words out
his mouth and then we did a podcast the
very next day we did the end the world
podcast we hung out all night and he was
like let's do another one we want to
support this hour when I first did his
podcast I remember as we were doing it
my phone would not stop buzzing and I
was getting followers I got in the car
from just doing his podcast and then the
live stream went out in the car I had
three thousand extra followers when I
got to the car when I got home and they
posted it that night the next morning I
woke up and I was like I was at 10,000
followers and I was like holy [ __ ] like
and it skyrocketed I mean I got to like
I want to say I got to like 50,000
followers on Twitter right after that
yeah like so it is sort of like part of
Duggan eyes banter on stage that was
funny was we sort of there's a lot of
ball busting yeah but then sometimes
that would translate to up
here's you know he'd be like time for
the plugs all right grams always got a
lot of crap to plug it was like
sometimes I was like uh hey guy that
makes three times what I make I need it
[ __ ] eat you know like you know so
that was the thing that was sort of and
then when he started doing that the
getting dug with high on YouTube that
brought in a very different audience the
YouTube audience it's so funny because I
really and I've said this out loud a lot
getting done with high is one of my
favorite podcasts one it's a great video
podcast but I enjoy it more as a podcast
like there have been times and there's
like it really is this thing some people
get too high and they don't know what
they're [ __ ] saying anymore and like
I remember there was one comic I won't
say his name but he was talking about
touring with another comic and they were
like man crazy [ __ ] must have happen
with you guys is like at one time he's
growing to like back of the boss and she
she wanted to sleep with the one guy but
they sent me in an I [ __ ] her Doug
like I think that's rape Shh no no no
it's not right and like like holy [ __ ] I
could I music's laughing I was like I
think you're talking about nicely
assaulting somebody but like that's what
I love I love getting done with high I
would never do it because of the girl my
daughter's right but I wouldn't do it
for a long time because of travel
channel and and now i think you know i
don't know maybe i do it but but that's
an interesting group of podcast
listeners like they're really like into
petty q zor's there and they're not doug
loves movies' fans right they're
completely different things loves movies
fans aren't just owners yeah I smell of
them are but some of them are movie fans
[ __ ] yeah they're knowledgeable movie
fans and they're a lot of them are
really into the gameplay oh yeah like
that they want they wanted played right
they want they want contestants that are
knowledgeable and smart and like get
into it they really really want that I
think that was part of it too so like
there would be like this adversarial
thing between me and Samm Levine
and so and Doug played that up and was
like hash tag team Sam or hash tag team
gram so then people would be like [ __ ]
ill would you know so it was like a it
was a very unique thing like I I still
do it every once in a while and he's
like yeah when earbuds is ready come on
and that's cool but it's a very there's
no other show like that there's nothing
there's nothing he you know he's carved
a very unique path for himself in his
genius the 420 shows on Saturdays and
sunny I thought I was gonna he's got the
high court's coming out is his new TV
show really central oh yeah um but like
he's really carved a unique path for
himself that it like they and I've said
this to him I'm sure if I hadn't haven't
that I'm doing it definitely now but
I'll reason I started doing the call in
sick to work shows was because he was
doing these for 20 shows and they're
selling out and I noticed that they were
events they weren't just like a stand-up
show it was a [ __ ] event and dude the
thing it was so smart about like I was
on the road with him from from like 08
through 14 basically and it was like 29
2009-2010 around there 10 he was like
I'm done doing full weeks it shows
because we would super high me it just
come out so like thursday night and
sunday night at the clubs would be the
stoners but then friday saturday
sometimes you just have regular comedy I
remember like a woman like in Grand
Rapids was came out and complained to
the manager that this this guy is
talking about drugs too much you know
like and he was like I don't want to
battle these people that don't know who
i am and get offended at pot jokes girls
said that he was like I'm tired of
[ __ ] performing for people who don't
know me I know he was like it he's like
it you should know me I don't think he
said that in that so many words but he
stopped doing weekends and I was like
I'm just gonna do one nighters and just
have my fans come out and I told him I
thought that was short-sighted exactly i
said i think when you the benefit to
doing the weekend of the club is you you
get fans that's how you get people to
see you do your thing and he was like i
don't see that benefit he was like i say
you get fans by putting out specials and
doing a good podcast segura and I you
want to talk about really interesting
crossover we don't have
a lot of the same fans the way you'd
think we would like all my fans everyone
let's my pack of my podcast loves when
he's on my podcast but when he started
doing the that when we started doing the
fat shaming contest between the two of
us if we were both stunned by how many
people did not know we were friends like
wow and yeah and we're probably he's
probably my closest friend but people
just didn't know the key had a group of
podcast listeners that did not know Bert
Kreischer well that's a great that's so
it's so funny because you can thank you
have an idea but like I don't know how
many times i would go either open up for
Doug on the road or do Doug loves movies
and people I'm gonna do a show with him
in just the end of this month down in
San Diego I guarantee you I we'd go to
these cities and people would come up to
me go wow I didn't know what you looked
like they'd listen to me on his show a
million time never once thought to like
get your special look never google it
never never add me never follow me and
I'd be like I go you know if you just
type in comedian Graham you're gonna
probably find it was not like I'm gonna
[ __ ] I'm gonna I'm when I'm with
again I'm you gotta get out of here yeah
okay we'll wrap this up but like I my
podcast okay the only two things I'm
gonna ask you left is I was gonna say do
you find your do find podcasting numbers
have increased in the last say of say
year um I gotta send this text real
quick cuz we're doing another show hold
on oh sorry that's okay it's my fault i
end up getting into these conversations
and they keep [ __ ] keep rambling my
podcast numbers have increased
astronomically in the last year like and
i feel like and i started a roegan about
it i think more people are coming to the
medium and more people are finding
podcasts i also think that the tom and
his fat and burtis fat war that went on
I think that was ultimately good for me
because I think I I had a lot of people
this weekend going I didn't even know
who you were until I heard Saburo making
fun of you and then I've heard I'm now
fam you're like I think I think I think
it's a good point I think more people in
general so five six years ago there was
some statistic that's something like
seventy eighty percent of the population
didn't even know what a podcast was I
think that number is coming down because
you have things like cereal got
mainstream media attention Obama on WTF
got mainstream media attention so I
think more people even know what it is
now taking earbuds to all these film
festivals at ever and I did Romania I
did Napa Valley I did all these
festivals at every screening there were
people who knew nothing about it and
just saw podcast documentary in the
program and we're like what is this how
do I get involved and you know I'd
always say pull out your iphone you have
a nap and they'd be like so [ __ ] easy
and they'd be like no I'd be like yeah
you know it's purple press it there you
go set up for company film nerds
subscribe you got it I put that so many
people wait I don't get this podcast go
subscribe there you go I just lined up
to five struggles yang oh really yeah
it'll be on your phone yeah I can win
when do they when do they premiere
[ __ ] idiot what channel there's not
you just [ __ ] it's on you're gonna
tip board can I get it in my car oh can
you hook up your [ __ ] phone your car
cuz yeah yeah [ __ ] yeah do you listen to
music off your phone well of course same
thing friend so but no the thing I've
noticed though is and yes comedy film
nerds numbers have gone up in the last
year I think we've we've done some stuff
like we started buying Twitter followers
not the fake BOTS but like the Twitter
advertising like if you like Kevin Smith
listen to comedy film nerds and and
stuff like that we know this week
because we noticed a fall off a little
bit in our numbers like a year or so ago
like what the [ __ ] my followers it's you
go through Twitter cuz you'll want to
buy fake followers you want to get
engaged fans so what you do with
Twitter's you go in and and you say who
should like this so we you pick about 10
or 12 account so we like Kevin Smith
Chris Hardwick AMC movies you know mean
Warner Brothers you know like and so if
you follow the Skrillex Lamar's girlie
what is it
Scorsese no no no the guy that bought
the AIDS medication and made it seven
hundred dollars a bill but yeah
subscriber that guy it's great like a
fake Burt Reynolds it cannot trouble
yeah it's gonna buy all the wrong ones
just to get the war for all the bucket
I'm looking for all the toxic twitter
users yeah they're worse people i'm
looking for trolls I just want rules all
my followers are trolls so yeah you go
through that anyway but like yeah we and
we noticed to our show we put the title
of it when we talk about a big movie we
get more listeners so which opens you
know like if because we'll just say
episode 3 25 you know the Civil you know
captain america or whatever but if we do
like an indie film it gets less so yeah
it's I think it's gone up I think more
people are into it i wanta what whatever
last question and one plug some dates
what episode would you suggest people to
go to and listen to as their
introductory episode you know I would
listen to one of the more I mean there's
you know what I would tell the listener
go to our catalog and find a movie that
you really liked or something rival yeah
i'm looking about one go do that that's
what i would say go through our catalog
and say oh this movie I want to hear you
guys talk about that or if there's a
guest you really enjoy Zootopia yeah who
the Reverend Suicide Squad I'll listen
to that one yeah I'm download that one
all right um and then what up working
people to watch a movie so earbuds the
podcasting documentary is currently
exclusively available at comedy film
reds.com we sell standard def and high
def downloads and also you can download
a bonus features it's about an hour
extra content DVDs were pre selling
those will be done in the next couple
weeks it's taking us a little longer and
then it'll be on itunes and all that
stuff in a couple of months but if you
want to get it now and you can see Burt
talking mad knowledge about one of my
favorite lines in that is like I said
something like oh yeah I've talked a lot
of [ __ ] about people oh yeah you can't
talk [ __ ] about anybody more than you
here read banging on here is laughs it's
[ __ ] i love that how that whole came
together you just
walked in and we had the camera rolling
and you just started talking and it made
it into the movie i [ __ ] love the
whole I [ __ ] Paul Tompkins I still
won't speak because of that it's so
great guys with feelings and [ __ ] how
long ago was that I'd have to podcast oh
well thank you for doing this man dude
congrats on the movie is [ __ ]
fantastic please tell me the password
again so I want to watch the end of it
sure um and and I can't wait to listen I
got a flight Wednesday morning so I'll
be listening to too which one did I just
download all right yeah comedy
filmous.com you can get the podcast
there you get the film follow us on
twitter at comedy film nerds I'm at
Graham Elwood
we'll have you on County
[Music]
you
this episode was brought to you by the
Machine
you